we're going to have a look at this
question this is the real question but
this is the structure that you'll often
see it in and I hope that as we go
through this the techniques that we've
started to develop the stuff to kill
this I need a red marker so we're going
to graph these that's going to be the
the technique that we use to help us
soul okay
so we'll begin with the first thing that
you can see this is the easiest part
your last to grab an absolute value
function okay so I want you to remember
what one I equals the absolute value of
X minus one
looks like last time we thought okay we
will deal with this by that's too high
with this fight now it's the father's
legal who deal with this by cases it
required a lot of algebra and writing
stuff out I'm going to try and take a
little more of a visual approach today
which shouldn't sit on its own you need
the algebra as well but hopefully when
you see these sort of overlap with each
other okay so to go he's a way that you
can graph y equals the absolute value of
X minus 1 without very much knowledge
about required for starters what we want
to draw is a sub eventual supplemental
plan which is y is X minus 1
clearly wife is X minus 1 and y equals
the absolute value of X minus 1
I'm very closely related okay so maybe
in my pencil on top of your axes maybe
in my pencil you can draw y equals x
minus 1 I don't really do what good luck
is y so I'm just going to this is what
line whose x place on the clock okay are
you content with that
are we good enough to recognize the
straight lines that when you see X minus
1 you think gradient y-intercepts okay
there's my picture right
okay now again rather than appealing to
the out drop I'm gonna look at this
[ __ ] take now if that's what regular x
-1 looks like what's the difference if I
stop obviously that you start driving
well whether this live is positive the
absolute value of a positive thing is
just lifting itself right so see all
that stuff that's above through the
x-axis
it doesn't need to change the absolute
value of that time is still that line ok
so you did it lightly to draw that sort
of construction line but now you can put
this nice and solid because like that's
plot that I want alright then you look
at the other part now that's a negative
section and we know from the definition
of absolute value when the stuff inside
is negative we want to slap another
negative sign on to bring it up to the
positive part and that's why when we saw
the very first time we drew this the
absolute value graphs are often called
bouncing rats right so you can see this
part up here I am going to reflect
across the x-axis I'm gonna reflect it
vertically okay which is why it ends up
looking like this so you didn't have to
think too hard about the algebra but if
you slap the minus sign in front of y
equals x plus 1 you're going to get why
it was 1 minus X okay and the labeling
of the grass is very important ok so far
so good
so what I've done is now I've got the
first graph then they asked us to graph
this other one on the same set of axes
well I should say it didn't say the same
set of axes
I didn't say them but if you're going to
use them to solve for points of
intersection which is like this means
tell me what these graphs intersect with
each other they're not going to be very
much used if there are two separate axes
so together if you have another column a
I'm gonna look at 1/2 X plus 1 okay what
does hop X plus 1
look like well conveniently I actually
have a way to sit there what is that one
intercept it's going to be 1 because and
why does it down here would have been in
negative 1 right it wouldn't be negative
1 by reflected in remember that okay so
that's one which is convenient because
positive 1 also happens to be the one
dissent here right what's the difference
though can you tell me can you describe
this line apart from this wire since
it's a it's not as steep right in fact
it's hafiz feet every time you go across
one unit you only go up huh so we can
draw that in it's going to look
something like this
now you'll notice what I've done here is
I've kind of rehearse the same process
we went through for the black line y
equals x minus 1 sorry X not as straight
as I'd like it to me and knowing that if
I just have it graph without a 2 value
sign that's what it's gonna look like
right there's that half grade you get
the idea now I'm going to reflect it
upwards this part over here ok just like
before
I should label my at my own different
branches this is ready roll 1/2 X plus 1
and this is the negative version which
is now I should point out when I went
from this version to this version I
switched them around right because if
you take something like 5 minus 2 and
you want the negative version of that if
it's a difference you can reverse the
order okay
however over here it doesn't make as
much sense to reverse the order because
they're both gonna get they do sides on
them right so this is just a cause of
anything just looks slightly different
but there's no reason to write that one
first because you're gonna have a minus
sign anyway so there you go it's done is
ready for signing
more obvious wonderful now what are we
trying to do I've done my grandmas what
was the point of the gratis yeah I want
to know where the grass collide with
each other that's where they are exactly
equal to one another you can actually
see where those points are on your graph
your graph will be even better than my
it's a bit terrible with the scale and
the curves or I'll have you but there is
one point of intersection and there is
the other now here is where it's going
to be so useful we're going to battle
you out of the fact that we labeled the
branches remember I said pay label
though they're just more lines
everywhere and don't tell me what they
are
tell me what each of the equations is
here is why you see that the black
branches intersects with this branch
that's glued you see that have a look at
this branch over here do you see that
he's completely irrelevant to puppy to
me solving the rest of this question why
is he completely irrelevant
he doesn't intersect and even though I
don't have the whole polygraph I know
he'll never intersect never everybody
could throw it all the way to negative
infinity and it's not gonna happen why
is that it's because the gradient right
you can see they're actually diverging
from one another this guy is climbing up
this one's climbing but not as fast okay
so therefore I can safely eat nor that
why cause half X minus one it's then I'm
just gonna solve when this guy is equal
to this and when this guy is equal to
that and that will give me two solutions
okay